hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Caroll if any of you out there own a
copy of my book something deeply hidden
you can go to the copyright page the
page right after the title page where
there's the copyright information Etc
printed in the United States of America
or whatever there is a little notation
on that page that gives the version
number and the version number is not
your copy of the book personally
all of you and your friends and I and
everyone else that we know has the same
version number and the version number is
756 trillion 132 billion 390 milon
553 if you know the story about what
that version number is when I wrote the
book I generated a Quantum random number
between one and a quadrillion
an integer and that's what this version
number is if you believe or if you for
the moment imagine that the world is
described by the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which I explain and defend in the book
then there are different branches of the
wave function with almost exactly the
same book written in them but different
version numbers every different integer
of that size is represented somewhere on
the branches of the wave function of the
universe somewhere it's all zeros or all
threes or whatever and there's got to be
some comment in that version of the book
well wow I guess we got really unlucky
about that but this idea this little
joke that we sneaked into the book was
supposed to be a way of really making
you face up to the claims involved in
the many world's formulation of quantum
mechanics and those claims I am very
quick to admit are weird they are
bizarre the implications of the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics are very very far away from
our intuitive everyday experience of the
world and some people will say you know
what they're too far away I'm just not
going to go there I do not believe there
are a quadrillion different versions of
something deeply hidden out there and
some Quantum Quantum Multiverse with
different version numbers in them so
what are we to do about that objection
that this idea the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
just too weird because quantum mechanics
is not the only place where this issue
arises there are other attempts to make
sense of the world to in other words
understand it even better than we do
that like it or not lead us to some
place that seems bizarre and weird to us
that is the theme of Eric schwitz
Gable's new book Eric is a philosopher
at University of California Riverside
and he has a new book that is going to
come out tomorrow by the day that this
podcast gets released and it is
literally called the weirdness of the
world and in this book he basically
faces up to the fact that some of our
best attempts to make sense of the world
end up looking pretty weird in fact he
argu that in some cases they're going to
have to look pretty weird there is no
version of the correct theory that
doesn't look weird to us now weird is an
interesting thing weird in his
definition of it is a little bit
different from bizarre he he defines
bizarre to mean contrary to our common
sense and weird is a little bit stronger
than that it's contrary to our common
sense in kind of an irrevocable way it's
not going to go away just because we
understand it better we're going to have
to buy into it so he talks about not
only quantum mechanics but Consciousness
is a big theme all the different
versions of Consciousness Theory just
like all the different versions of the
foundations of quantum mechanics Eric
will argue involve a certain degree of
weirdness and there's other weird things
that that may just be false like maybe
we live in a simulation or maybe we're
brain in a vet or whatever maybe those
you can dismiss but what about when you
can't dismiss it what do you do when you
to balance different levels of weirdness
of different kinds of theories should we
just ignore the weird possibilities
should we give substantial Credence to
them should we be more cautious when all
the options on the table are pretty
weird so I like it as a work of
philosophy that faces up to the real
challenges that come along with taking
seriously our best ways of understanding
the world so over the course of all of
our different podcasts here we've gone
to some pretty weird places we might as
well celebrate it let's
[Music]
go Eric schwitz skap welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks for having me
so you've written a book about the
weirdness of the world which uh is just
a great provocative title that I'm sure
will give us a lot to talk about but
before we do that I have to bring up a
couple things that you've also been
involved with that are really
interesting but not on that topic but I
have to get them out of the way a little
bit one is virtual Dan dennet you know
we uh had Dan dennet as a previous
mindscape guest I think that's his claim
to fame these days uh but those are
before the days when we had large
language models and could just program
up a Dan dennet to to interview so you
did that and did a little experiment
tell us about that yeah we sure did so
this we did this I should say this is
collaborative with Anna ster and my son
David
schable and uh Matthew Crosby was a
collaborator earlier on but he had to
leave uh to work for deep mind that
happens yeah so he couldn't publish
something using open AI
technology I'm sure he's handsomely
compensated for his
problems he was involved early on uh and
actually did some of the fine tuning so
um so people know chat GPT probably most
of your listeners know right this is a
large language model it can produce text
it's very humanlike uh a precursor to
that that came out I think in 2020 is uh
was
gpt3 yeah and one of the things that you
could do with gpt3 was you could find
tune it on a corpus of text so it's
basically it consumes large portions of
the internet and from this it can
predict the next word when you input
likely text so when you find tuna what
you do is you add some more Corpus and
then it readjusts its weights so that
its outputs look like a compromise
between what it is and its original
state and the Corpus that you've input
you f- tuned it on so what we did was we
took gpt3 and we f- tuned it on the
Corpus of Dan dennet about two million
words uh most of his I don't know how
many books as in the teens uh and
articles uh we we just pumped them into
GPT and then what we did was we asked
the actual Dan dennet 10 philosophical
questions and we asked our fine tune
model we call digian the same 10
questions we got we did it four times we
got four answers uh from each of the
digi Dan we didn't do any cherry picking
of those answers to see for Quality we
did make sure that they were sufficient
length
yeah uh so we excluded short answers we
wanted length similar to uh dennett's
own answers and then what we did was we
took experts in dennett's work and we
said hey can you guess which is Dennis's
real answer and which is come from the
model so chance would have been 20%
right the experts got it about 50% right
so they did better than chance but still
half the time they chose the the model's
answer over dennett's answers and on two
of the questions the plurality of
experts actually chose one of the
model's answers over dennett's answer
and in one of the questions dennet said
you know what I kind of see why the
experts chose that answer over my own
answer if I thought about it more I
should have said something different so
arguably on one question uh the model
actually outperformed Dan
himself so so anyway that was our
experiment we wrote it up we published
it and it was a lot of fun and when you
did it it was only a short while ago but
probably it was much more surprising at
the time it wasn't quite as public the
whole uh excitement these days about
large language
models that's right we did it we
actually ran the experiment before chat
GPT was released and so people were
getting the wind about the power of gpt3
but it wasn't quite the phenomenon that
it has since become and you when you
just as a technical matter when you
download this Corpus does that mean you
had to have electronic copies of all of
Dan's writings did he help you with that
or did you just pirate a book or get a
Kindle edition he helped us with this
and he collaborated with us on the
project throughout um and anest ster did
a huge amount of work converting these
old PDFs okay and junky files into clean
text that could be uploaded into the
model but you've written things you have
a Blog you have you been tempted to do
this for yourself too that that save you
time Yes actually the first thing we did
was we uh uploaded my blog into this so
we didn't this didn't become a
publication but uh we uploaded our blog
into my blog into GPT uh 3 uh kind of
lower power version of it actually not
the D Vinci model but the uh cury model
which is a slightly lower powered
version and then we had it produce blog
posts in the style and so readers can go
if they want look on my blog the
splintered mind and they can see the GPT
generated blog posts which were actually
pretty interesting I mean I don't I
think I write blog post better but but
it was kind of cool yeah and at the time
that we did this it was not generally
well known that GPT could create well
structured answers over long strings of
text I mean if you're thinking it's it
essentially does next word prediction so
you would kind of think it would lose
the thread of ideas over time and
wouldn't be able to create a well
structured argument that runs for
paragraphs and way that that's kind of
what we thought but it was surprising
one of the blog posts was I think not a
convincing argument but at least it had
a kind of philosophical argumentative
structure over the course of several
paragraphs which we found really
interesting and surprising giving given
the basic structure of these models so
clearly GPT does have some memory of
what it's recently said right it's it's
not literally going from one word to
another right it's got a a window of I
forget how something like a thousand
tokens you know tokens like three4 of a
word um something in that
ballpark um so yes so did you give it
topics for those blog posts or did you
just say write another blog post that
would fit in
here we gave it titles okay and then it
wrote the post uh given the title yeah
this is very scary do you think that the
this the world is going to change
dramatically because of this
technology yes yeah okay it's hard to
know exactly how it's going to change
know how right yeah okay but for sure
it's going to change so that was one
thing I wanted to get out of the way the
other one which I only found when I saw
your Wikipedia page is that you were one
of the people involved in asking the
questions are ethicists especially
ethical or does you know studying moral
philosophy make you a more moral person
is that
right yeah arguably I'm the world's
foremost expert on the moral behavior of
Ethics
professors and what are your conclusions
about
this well I've done it I've done a fair
number of empirical studies on this and
what I found over and over again almost
without
exception is that they behave about the
same
as comparison groups of other professors
so sometimes we do the comparison group
would be other philosophers who don't
specialize in ethics sometimes the
comparison group is other professors at
the same University in different
departments um and a there have been a
couple studies where we found a little
bit worse or a little bit better
behavior in some respects uh for
ethicists but generally speaking it's a
big null result well okay just find they
behave the same as other people uh which
I think is kind of interesting because
you might have thought that ethicists
would reflect on ethics and then behave
differently as a result of their
Reflections and mostly that seems not to
be the
case one particularly interesting
example of this is with respect to
vegetarianism because ethicists on some
issues will have will Embrace more
demanding moral
standards so for example ethicists are
much more likely than professors in
departments other than philosophy or
they were in 2009 when we collected
these data yeah to say that it's bad to
eat meat bad to eat the meat of M an in
particular is what we asked about uh and
yet in our research we found them just
as likely to report having eaten meat at
their previous evening
meal now is that correlated I mean are
there people who say it is bad to eat
meat also eating the
meat it uh right it it had the
correlation that you would think so the
people who we gave them a ninepoint
scale from uh very morally bad to very
morally good and the people who ticked
one or two very morally bad or one tick
uh toward good from that few of them
reported having eaten meat at their
previous evening meal but the ones who
ticked three or four on our ninepoint
scale which was a lot of
ethicists seemed basically just as
likely to have reported eating meat so
there was a individual there was a kind
of correlation between the strength of
the opinion right and the self-reported
eating but there wasn't the group
difference that we expected right so
ethesis as a group
said the majority 60% said it was
morally bad um
but I don't know 30 some perc of them
reported having done it their previous
evening meal nonetheless compared to I
think it was
30 8% of ethicists and and 37 no 37% of
ethicists and 38% of respondents overall
so if this is a surprising result which
I'll I'll entertain the possibility that
it is what's your theoretical
understanding what's going on is it just
that ethicists are better at arguing
about ethics but not actually better at
being ethical is there a different kind
of study that would make you better at
ethics is it like coaching versus
playing a
sport yeah I think coaching versus
playing is an interesting
comparison um we don't hire ethicists to
be Saints just like we don't hire
coaches to be football stars yeah and
yet you would expect if you took a a
coach and a random member of the
population of the same age and gender
and put them on a football field
together you would expect the coach
would still outperform right even if the
coach is not a superstar right right so
I think that's an interesting comparison
that reveals partly why you might think
it's a still a little surprising even if
we don't hold ethicists to stti
standards I mean in the vegetarianism
results again you know that I I think
that strikes people as somewhat
surprising um yeah
so one of the things that I draw from
this is it fits with uh a view I have
about moral psychology I'm not I suspect
the real answer is complex and
multi-causal but but one of the things I
think it fits pretty well with is uh the
idea that people in general aim to be
morally
mediocre Okay so my inclination is to
think and this is grounded you know both
in personal experience and in Reading
social and moral psychology right the
people don't generally aim to be good or
bad by absolute
standards instead they aim to be about
as morally good as their
peers they don't want to make the
sacrifices that would be involved in
being very morally
better uh but they also don't want to be
the worst in the bunch
interesting right so people aim for Pure
relative moral standards right so if you
think about that from the point of view
of thinking philosophically about ethics
maybe what you do when you think about
ethics is you discover moral truths like
maybe you discover it's bad to eat the
meat and mammals right but if you're
aiming just for peer relative goodness
your peers are still eating meat so what
happens is your opinion about your your
peer's moral behavior and your own moral
Behavior goes down
but your behavior doesn't change that's
actually very nicely consonant with
other podcasts I've done recently about
other aspects of things like psychology
or even
epistemology having much more of a
social slant than we would expect Brian
Lowry uh explained to us how our sense
of selves uh serves mostly a social
function uh Yugo Mercier explained how
our use of reasons explain it serves
largely a social function and you're
saying that there's a very big social
function that is served by our ethical
practice at any rate yeah right
absolutely social animals there we are
but I guess this does segue even more
smoothly than I thought it would into
the weirdness of the world because
there's the when you say the world is
weird and now we're going to get into
the topic of your book immediately part
of me wants to say come on the world
can't be weird it's the world what we're
seeing is a mismatch between our
expectations and the world and maybe
those can be colored somehow so what
does the title of your book
mean right so yeah you're right it's
it's not that the world is intrinsically
weird I'm not sure what that would
mean uh the idea of weirdness or bizar
which is a closely Rel idea in my book
uh
involves violating our expectations or
standards or a sense of what's normal or
violating common
sense so when I say that the world is
weird I mean something like our Common
Sense understandings of how the world is
are going to be sharply violated by how
the world actually is
that's a um that's the bizarreness
element and then there's also an element
which I call dubiety which is that and
all of our answers to this are dubious
it's not like oh well it violates common
sense but we perfectly well understand
it uh it's also a dimension of weirdness
is that it kind of exceeds our ability
to fully
comprehend right so I think the example
you gave in the book is special
relativity which tells us very things
that happen at the speed of light might
seem bizarre to us it's anti-common
sensical but it's not weird in the same
sense we can fully understand it once we
learn what's going on correct so special
relativity is a nice example of
something that's highly bizarre it
violates common
sense but it's not
dubious so the full weirdness thesis uh
also involves this dubi claim yeah yeah
you use the word dubiety in your book
much more often than I've ever seen it
used before so just to let people know
it's the uh the existence of or I guess
the the claim that you should be dubious
about
something right that doubt is Justified
doubt is Justified good you know the
name the URL of my personal website is
preposterous universe.com uh for exactly
the same reason it came out of thinking
about naturalness in cosmology and the
cosmological constant and the fact that
the universe is surpr uring to us uh and
it's funny because I get critics you
know the the usual crackpot on the
street with opinions about cosmology
saying oh Sean Carol thinks the universe
is preposterous he doesn't realize that
it's just our ideas that are wrong but
I'm trying to say like no that's the
point I don't think the universe is
making a mistake it's definitely we are
making a mistake that's the whole
message that is trying to get
across exactly and I like the word
Preposterous too I I was flirting with
just borrowing that word from you but I
decided I liked weirdness a little bit
better but weirdness Works especially
weirdness of the world the literation
ETC okay so is then if let's take the
universe's point of view here you know
why is it our fault that the Universe
looks weird to us is there something
about us that is despite the fact that
we're part of the world that kind of
doesn't quite match on to what we see
out there in
principle right well I'm inclined to
think that our theories and our Common
Sense well especially our Common Sense
let's start with that our common sense
is trained upon built upon a very
limited range of experiences yeah right
so with respect to Big Picture cosmology
right it's relatively low energy
middle-sized slow mov moving stuff on
Earth right and that's what we're good
at that's what we evolve to be good at
that's what the social pressures and
learning environment is makes us good at
you take something at a very different
scale much larger much smaller much more
energetic and those aren't the kinds of
things that there's any particularly
good evolutionary or developmental or
social reason to think we would have
well-tuned common sense judgments about
so in in other words the way that I've
said similar things in in some cases
we have we only experience a tiny
fraction of what the world is and but we
make efforts to experience more and more
of it and guess what it looks different
and surprising to us yes I completely
agree with that so and I think the same
is true for uh our understanding of
Consciousness although May less less
obviously so right so um the the thesis
of the weirdness of the world you know
is is partly about large big picture cos
cosm ological issues but it's also
equally or even more about Consciousness
yeah right so again with respect to
issues of Consciousness we're familiar
with the human case and with you know
certain familiar ver vertebrates we
like uh and that's about what we know
about Consciousness and we have not had
experience for example with
sophisticated AI systems yeah uh so
we shouldn't expect particularly to have
well-tuned common sensical intuitions
about such things good and so in some
sense I don't want to put words in your
mouth but it seems to me that the motto
of your book should be that you're
asking us to be
courageous to say you know uh we should
expect that as we learn more and more
about the world we'll we'll find that
what we're learning seems weird to us
and we need to develop tools and
techniques to deal with that and handle
it yeah
absolutely and yeah I guess that's in a
sense courageous
although I'm not sure that's the word I
would
use I like the word wonderful instead
okay because it's got this it's got two
the idea of wonderful it's got two
Dimensions to it right so it's got the
root sense of wonder right that we live
in a world that
promotes Wonder in
us and wonderful of course is also
something like a syn synonym for what
for good right right so and I think
that's a good thing about the world that
it's kind of defies our
understanding so you have lessons and
nostrums that we should get from
contemplating the the weirdness of the
world but I thought that maybe we could
just go through some examples really
think about them in depth and then that
will help us extract what these lessons
are and as you said Consciousness is a
big one but I first wanted to just talk
about the existence of the external
world you know these radically skeptical
scenarios like you you you talk a lot
about are we sure that we're
awake right for example so so give us
the general L of the land here like how
how do you think about these skeptical
possibilities and what are your favorite
ones right so
yeah have a few different chapters where
I tangle with these skeptical
possibilities in different ways um the
dream argument of course is uh a famous
one that's that's the one you you've
started with but I'm also interested in
the simulation hypothesis the idea that
we might be living in a simulation the
boltzman brain idea which you of course
talked about uh in your work uh very
wonderfully um
and you know just the idea that even the
idea that the Universe might consist
wholly of my own mind and nothing else
right so I talk about all of those
possibilities in the book um but we
could start with the dream one which is
maybe the most familiar one sure um so
this this goes back in philosophy all
the way at least to the ancient Chinese
philosopher janga although of course
deart makes famous use of it right the
idea
is how do you know if you do know that
you're not currently dreaming right
now
and normally we think we feel pretty
confident that we're awake at least if
you ask a waking person if they're
confident they're awake they'll tend to
say yes
yeah um but what justifies
that and I think there are a few ways it
could be
justified I think there are
some empirical features of
dreams that are that make it that make
them different from Waking Life so for
example I think of waking sensory
experience as pretty richly detailed and
pretty
stable whereas the experiences we have
in dreams
arguably are less detailed kind of
sketchier more image likee less stable
do you know this claim that in dream
there's a claim that I think actually
has some backing but I'm not sure how
right it is that you can't read text in
dreams the text does not look like text
it looks like that sort of bad AI text
it's sort of like letter likee without
actually having any
meaning yes that is sometimes called a
dream sign right these are hypothesized
tests for whether you're dreaming or not
so look at text and see if it's stable
and if you can read it and some people
think of that as for themselves a good
dream sign sign but of course there are
also dream reports in which people
report Reading stable text so it's not
yeah accepted all right
good
so right so so I think that if we if we
accept this fact about the stability of
text is as maybe at least in the
majority of dreams you can't have a
stable
text um that creates some evidence that
I'm not dreaming right
now but a lot of dream researchers
including for example Jennifer vent who
I think is really uh amazingly
knowledgeable about this kind of stuff
think that we do often in
dreams have stable experiences that are
a lot like Waking Life maybe even
experientially in indistinguishable from
Waking Life even moreing boring mundane
experiences like that of listening to a
podcast
that's a very exciting experience
Eric
and so if we think that there are some
dreams like this or if we invest some
Credence in a theory of dreaming
According to which there are either
often or at least sometimes experiences
like like I'm having right now or like
your listeners or you are having right
now in dreams then it becomes kind of
less experientially obvious okay I can't
now be sure that I'm not
dreaming based
on what seems to be this stable
experience that I'm having right now of
seeming to be awake and of course lots
of uh people including me and probably
most of your listeners listeners have
had false Awakening experiences where
you you kind of seem to wake up and
think oh I just had a dream now I'm
awake right and then you wake up
again right so there are reasons I think
not to be perfectly
certain that you are not dreaming right
now is it also worth contemplating a
kind of inception scenario where we are
all dreaming there's a there's a more
awake version of us uh that that dreams
like our existence when you know pretty
detailed we can read text Etc and then
we dream that We're Dreaming in in this
this fuzzier way
right I think that's possible but I
wanted to draw distinction between what
I think of as grounded and ungrounded
skepticism so ungrounded skepticism says
well I could be a brain in a that and
then I wouldn't be able to tell the
difference so can I really rule that out
right an ungrounded ungrounded dream
skepticism could be like oh well maybe
we're in an Inception scenario right uh
grounded skepticism starts with our
ordinary background assumptions and says
looking at these assumptions there's
some positive reason to give some
Credence to skeptical doubt right so
there's no real positive reason to think
that you're a brain in a vat
to assign that any more than the most
trivial likelihood right there's no
positive reason to think we're in an
Inception scenario but there is positive
reason to think that this experience
might be a dream experience once we
start thinking about the nature of dream
experiences and whether experiences like
this at least maybe sometimes occur in
dreams at least According to some
theories that might be true right so I
prefer to focus on this on these
grounded kind of uh sources of
skepticism so I think it's not just I
mean one of the critic one of the
critiques that philosophers sometimes
give a skepticism is you cook up
anything there's no reason for us to
take it seriously whereas I think with
dream skepticism given the fact that we
dream every night given that theories of
Dreams at least some mainstream theories
of Dreams postulate that we have
experiences like this in our sleep that
creates grounds for doubt it's not
completely just cooked up out of nothing
maybe you can add to that the idea that
at least most of the time While We're
Dreaming we don't think of ourselves as
dreaming right most of the time of
course there are some so-called lucid
dreams and it is the case that if you
can uh get yourself in the habit of
thinking am I awake yeah so much that
that thought starts to come to you while
you're actually dreaming then that's one
way to discover that you're dreaming and
have start to have lucid dreams I'm very
bad at remembering even in the dream
sometimes people will say am I dreaming
and then decide no I'm not dreaming even
though they really are that's just what
I was going to ask because I I I was
just going to say I don't remember my
own dreams very well at all but I I
don't have any memory of ever being in a
dream saying I wonder if I'm in a dream
and then going nope I don't think I am
but you're saying other people have
reported
that experience yes that's definitely
not an uncommon experience all right all
right now you see you're in the cas that
the majority of times when people are
dreaming and think to themselves
explicitly Am I Dreaming they come to
realize they are but it's not clear that
that's a majority and even if it is it's
not an overwhelming majority yeah okay
okay good um then what let let's just go
through some of the other famous ones
because you you drawn a very interesting
distinction between grounded and
ungrounded skeptical scenarios what are
some of the other skeptical scenarios
you would classify is grounded in other
words worthy of our attention so I find
the simulation hypothesis pretty
interesting so this is the idea that we
might be artificial intelligences living
inside a simulated reality kind of like
the Matrix except in The Matrix they're
really biological bodies but you might
you could have a matrix type scenario
where the the the confused entities are
AI systems right or you could imagine
the video game The Sims with these
official simulated people going around
these environments except the Sims are
really conscious yeah right those a
couple ways of thinking about the
simulation hypothesis right so uh Nick
Bostrom has a famous argument that gives
us some grounds for thinking it's at
least possible that we are sims right so
the idea here would
be
that it's
not ridiculous to think that
Consciousness could arrive in arise in
artificially intelligent computational
systems right philosophers have disputed
that uh John surl who was actually one
of my dissertation advisers is one of
the most famous Skeptics about that but
there's it's certainly no consensus that
it's
impossible so if we
accept give at least some
Credence to the possibility that
artificially intelligent beings could
arise on
computers then it seems possible that
such beings could exist in simulated
artificial environments that they take
to be their own the base level of
reality as Bostrom puts it uh some of
them might even think they're living in
Earth on the 20 in the 21st
century and then the question arises
okay how many such beings are there and
one possibility would be look you know
they're not ever going to be beings like
this out there right what the
civilization will not get that far
enough maybe it's just really expensive
to make such things and and no one would
bother or maybe there'd be some ethical
regulations like you don't want to
create real you want to create really
conscious entities inside your computer
who think they're living in reality
right but on the other hand it also
seems like it's possible that there
would be many such beings right it just
like like we run computer games like the
Sims right now and we run scientific
simulations it could be the case that
there are lots of games or scientific
projects that involve real conscious
beings inside them who think they're
living in the base level of reality if
the universe contains many such beings
then it seems not totally implausible to
think we might be among them so there
are various reasons to think we're
probably not them right every step of
this argument admits of Doubt yeah but
and you kind of Stack those doubts on
top of each other and it seems like okay
probably not right but again it's like
with a dream case it doesn't seem like
we should be absolutely certain that
we're not Sims right so yeah I guess it
could be so I find that possibility
interesting and then um I guess to turn
this into a skeptical scenario so one of
the things
that uh David chamers has particularly
emphasized in talking about this is he
says well look if you're living in a
simulation but it's large and stable
then that's not really a skeptical
scenario at all he says because you have
a long past you're going to have a long
future all the people you know really
exist and you know there might be say a
coffee mug and it might be fundamentally
made out of computational bits but you
know that's enough it's we could still
it's still going to be there it's going
to react the way that you want so it
really is kind of a coffee mug uh so all
basically most of your ordinary beliefs
would end up being
true so to turn this into a skeptical
simulation scenario what we have to do
is think about what's the possibility
that if we're living in a Sim it's a
small or unstable
one and there I guess I'm inclined to
disagree with
chamers um and I'm inclined to think
that if we are in a Sim there's a decent
chance that it's a small or unstable one
so if we think about the simulations we
run they tend to be small and
unstable uh if we think about the
question of resources right
and it probably would take a lot of
resources to run a whole galaxy from The
Big Bang through now and on into the
future so what scientist is really going
to want to do that if maybe all they're
interested in is human cognition right
so just run a short you know a few
people having a discussion on a podcast
right or something like that so I think
conditional upon thinking we're living
in a Sim we should assign a substantial
portion of that Credence you know maybe
50% maybe 90% maybe 10% to it's being a
smaller unstable simulation right and in
that case then that in my mind counts as
a a radically skeptical scenario because
you might be radically wrong maybe this
whole simulation was created only 10
minutes ago or maybe you know there's no
one outside of your room it's just you
listening to a podcast or just the two
of us having a conversation and and
Beyond the walls of our rooms nothing
exists right those would be various ways
of it's being small or unstable so as a
professional philosopher of course you
know that the idea of the skeptical
scenarios goes back to Antiquity uh not
just janga but uh the ancient Greeks
thought about this so we've been worried
for Millennia now that reality is not
anything like what we think it is
absolutely uh I I love the uh the
ancient
Skeptics so what are some of your
favorite
ones well draga is probably my favorite
philosopher uh but uh sexus empiricus is
also really
wonderful and they did not know about
the simulation
argument right they didn't know about
the simulation argument so that opens up
the possibility that there are some
grounds for doubt that future
philosophers and physicists will think
of that didn't even occur to
us and maybe we should have some degree
of
skepticism reserved for that right I
call this wild card skepticism the idea
that I am I should have a certain amount
of doubt about my ordinary assumptions
about the world just on the basis of the
fact that there's some skeptical
possibility that I'm not not even
capable of considering right okay good
so there are other skeptical scenarios
but we have the general feeling between
living in a simulation we're just
dreaming what do we do about it do
we just ignore those possibilities
because they're too weird do we uh
reserve a little bit of our credences to
say you know who knows maybe tomorrow
will change my mind and think that this
is
right yeah I think we reserve a little
bit of our Credence so so the way that I
think about it in terms of numerical
Credence is that I think it's rational
to assign about a 0.1 to
1% Credence to some radically skeptical
scenario or other being
correct you know that's rough and fuzzy
right it's somewhere between you know
just being completely confident they're
false and being you know kind of
radically uncertain so 99%
99.9% the world's basically just how we
think it is right um setting aside the
kind of cosm the big picture
cosmological stuff right but kind of the
ordinary Earth world of middle siiz Dry
Goods at slow speeds is is more or less
how we think 99% 99.9% of our Credence
maybe should go to that but we save a
little bit of your Creedence space so to
speak for these radically skeptical
possibilities and then I think that that
having that little bit of space there
can have some influence on your on your
choices and your behavior actually I I
do want to get to exactly that issue but
I realize there's a hanging thread that
we should deal with which is there's
another kind of way in which the world
could be very different I mean world
could be very different than what we
think it is which is just there is a
lower microscopic level beneath our
manifest image kind of world right so
you're not
counting we are not talking about
something like oh there's a whole new
Theory uh where everything is little
strings or wave functions or whatever
like that doesn't count because in those
scenarios the macroscopic world is still
the macroscopic world and obeys the
rules right exactly right so I don't
count that as a radically skeptical
scenario of the relevant sort because
there still would be our everyday
beliefs would still mostly be true right
right it would be true that you know
Earth has existed for billions of years
and it would be true that you know
there's a coffee mug here and that sort
of stuff and the sun will will rise
tomorrow so to
speak good okay good so then let's then
we can go back to that one 1% skepticism
that you're advocating I mean one
question is just where did that number
come from you're saying we should attach
a 10 Theus 2 10 the minus 3 Credence to
just being completely wrong uh I I
absolutely agree that we should attach
some Credence to any crazy idea you have
I I'm I'm a disbeliever that you should
attach zero Credence to almost anything
but why not 10 to the minus 10 why why
something as as big as 10 the minus two
or
three I don't have a rigorous argument
for
that but let me just do it for say the
dream scenario yeah right so let's say
we invest a 20% Credence in the theory
which some major dream researchers
accept that we commonly have experiences
like we're currently having in our
dreams let's say we get 20% Credence to
that and 80% Credence to now dreams are
basically just always sketchy right then
conditional on that we say okay how
often do I have experiences relevantly
like this in dreams well you know maybe
this is a not the kind of thing that I
would tend to dream about very much
right but again you know this is if if
we ordinarily have kind of sensory
ordinary kind of sensory experiences of
mundane things it seems like this is the
kind of thing that we should have so
maybe I should assign you know a
2% maybe 2% of the time I'm having
experiences like this is actually in
sleep or I should invest 2% of my
Credence to the idea that uh I have
experiences like this in my
sleep now once I've attached a 2%
Credence to the idea that I have
experiences like this commonly in my
sleep it's hard for me to see on the
basis of that how you would then go okay
so I now only have a a one in 10 billion
Credence that this is a
dream right it seems
like you you can't knock too many orders
of magnitude down off off that 2% with
kind of I'm not sure what the epistemic
what the grounds would be for for that
kind of decrement
uh I think it's a big philosophical
problem that I don't know whether you
know if anyone sort of specializes in
this particular question but what do we
do with issues or questions or scenarios
where the Credence that it'll happen is
incredibly tiny but the conse quences of
it happening are incredibly large and it
seems you know maybe AI destroying the
world is an example of that or even
better because people think that AI
destroying the world might be 10% but
the Large Hadron Collider turning on and
a black hole eating up the world and
someone says well it's less than a one
in 10 billion chance and someone else
says but it destroys the world that that
should still count how do we reason
about those cases one and 10 billion
times 10 billion people so that's I
chose the number expected it's one
expected murder as soon as you turn it
on but even the number one in the 10
billion I mean if someone said oh no
it's really only one in 10 million or
it's one in 10 trillion probably I
couldn't give a principled
argument in any of those Direction I
when talk about those kinds of
magnitudes sometimes it's hard to
get you lose your sense of magnitude
once you get over I don't know a
trillion or something like that so do
philosophers have a toolkit for dealing
with these weird
numbers
no it's become an it's an interesting
issue that's been starting to get
attention in the philosophical
literature um you know there's this idea
that sometimes called nickan discounting
which is the which is the thought that
once something has a low enough chance
or you give a low enough Credence to it
you just ignore it completely yeah yeah
so that is one approach what was that
called and I nickan uh
discounting uh after someone named
Nicholas but I forg forgotten uh which
Nicholas it is um so right so for
example in the weirdness of the world I
suggest that once you give something 10
to the -30
Credence you kind of just forget about
it and and this helps solve certain
kinds of puzzles and paradoxes in
decision Theory um but there are also
arguments against this so there's been
back and forth about this this is Al
also comes up in the debate about the
ethics of long-termism right exactly
right so long-termism is this idea in
the effective altruism movement that
there's a small chance that things we do
today could have a huge impact on a huge
number of lives in the
future right right so for example if
Humanity goes extinct now then maybe
there are no other entities in our
galaxy who will ever have the kinds of
lives uh with the kind of value that our
lives have right and if we manage not to
go extinct now then maybe we will have
10 to the 40 happy descendants uh before
the heat death of the universe right so
even if there is a one in a quadrillion
chance that something you did now could
prevent Humanity from going
extinct given the stakes maybe you
should invest a huge amount right in
that tiny little
chance so that's that's yeah so that's
this interesting issue that's been
coming up recently with uh with
long-termism that where this issue about
how do you what do you do when you're
trying to balance tiny credences and
giant values against each other do you
have a take on what we should do or is
it just an open kind of question
um so I have two takes one is I I I'm
still going to stand by uh Nicolosi
discounting okay and the other take is
radical ignorance
about what would be what actions that
are currently available to us would have
good versus bad effects so the
long-terms will typically say or
assume that human extinction
is likely to have a bad effect instead
of a good effect on the on future
history I don't think that that's
necessarily
true uh so for
example uh maybe Humanity because we are
so
technological and prone to
violence uh is a kind of unstable
species that is more or less certain to
Doom
itself some time in the next 10 to
100,000 years we're going to blow
ourselves
up but and if we do it in a explosive
way then we ruin the Earth for other
future
inhabitants but if we were to say bow
out peacefully Now by deciding never to
reproduce again as antinatalists suggest
then maybe we leave the Earth in a good
position for other species like say
dolphins mhm which might who might have
descendants that are capable of lives as
rich as ours but who aren't
technological aren't going to blow
themselves up and could endure
potentially for billions of years on the
planet or maybe not billions but maybe a
billion
uh if that's the case then and you put
the numbers into the equation in a
certain way then maybe it turns out that
it' be better from a kind of long-term
perspective for human beings to
uh peacefully extinguish ourselves
now so I'm not saying that's true what
I'm saying is it's very hard to know
yeah what really when you take a
billion-year Time perspective what
really is kind of objectively good
versus bad among options that we have
available to us now I think that's fair
so so radical ignorance about the very
distant
future and relatedly then what is the
actionable fact about 1% skepticism like
how does it affect our daily lives to
think that maybe there's a 1% chance or
a tenth of a percent chance that I'm
Dreaming or that I'm living the
simulation right um well for
example just a fun example to start with
I had been reading a lot about dream
skepticism and it was particularly Vivid
for me this one particular uh winter
break when I was walking across a campus
and and no one else was around and I was
thinking I wonder if I'm Dreaming maybe
I should try to fly because I'm probably
not dreaming but look if I'm Dreaming it
would be so awesome to fly and no one's
around no one's looking there's no no
cost I was kind of walking across campus
to the science library to get a book
right so why not just like try to fly to
the library so I did try to fly fly to
the library and I failed H but uh but I
think that was a rational
decision
because I could have been dreaming and
then it would have been awesome it was
not so rational that you would have done
it had people been
watching right so lowcost things right
don't try to fly when you're standing on
the edge of the cliff yeah all right
plug that into your utility calculus and
you will not get a positive result right
but if they're no if they're very small
or no costs to trying to fly uh
then why not if you think this might be
a dream could
fly well the other thing of course as
soon as you try to fly and fail then
that should reduce your Credence either
that this is a dream or that if this is
a dream you could
fly so you might it might not be
repeatable you might not just be
spending all of your time trying to fly
in my dreams I can fly at least a little
bit I can
float
right it's just a matter of willpower
um anyway this is all you know fun but
it is 1% stuff and uh a lot of the book
I don't want to give people the wrong
impression a lot of your book you're
talking about Consciousness which has
the feature that we're all familiar with
it I don't even want to say the feature
that it exists because people argue
about that but at least we're all
familiar with the idea so what is it
about our attempts to understand
Consciousness that drives us into the
weird
zone right so philosophers have
tried over and over again for centuries
to make sense of how Consciousness fits
into the
world and one of the Striking empirical
facts about the history of philosophy is
that every single attempt to make sense
of this is jaw-droppingly
bizarre
so there are I divide attempts to deal
with the question of how Consciousness
fits into the broader world into four
broad categories one is substance
dualism you've got an immaterial Soul
another one is materialism there are no
immaterial souls you're just a
biological
entity another one is idealism this is
the idea that there is no Material World
at all all that exists are minds or
souls and then there's a what I call
compromise SL rejection views this kind
of grab bag of other
Alternatives and and the Striking thing
to me about this is all of these
Alternatives end up committing to
bizarre and
dubious thesis of one form or another
there's not really a live option here
that is non-bizarre it's not always
obvious I mean idealism is bizarre on
its face I think right it's contrary to
Common Sense to think there's no
material world and it's only just Minds
right dualism and materialism are not
maybe bizarre in their face but once you
try to get into the metaphysical details
and think about how it really works end
up pretty swiftly faced with theoretical
choices where they're going to be
bizarre consequences for any of the
choices that you make I think that's the
important point because people are going
to hear you say that and and there'll be
both materialists and dualists in the
audience who go I have no trouble
thinking that Consciousness works that
way but your point is that if you really
take the consequences of that view
seriously you're led to something that
we should recognize as
bizarre correct right so why don't you
tell us for either one yeah yeah so for
example with dualism right the dualist
faces two questions where all of the
answers seem to be bizarre one concerns
what kinds of entities have souls and
the other concerns the C caal
relationship between material world and
souls uh the causal question is a little
more complicated so but so let me just
talk about the the question of what
entities have souls right basically you
have four choices you could say only
humans have souls MH or you could say
everything in the world has a
soul uh both of those are pretty bizarre
right because if you if you think souls
are the Locust of Consciousness then if
you SE accept the first
like decart then you think dogs and cats
aren't conscious right so there's a
story of decart taking a cat and
throwing it out of a second story window
saying see cats are they they're just
machines I never heard that story he
probably didn't actually do this man but
but that story kind of reveals the
bizarreness of this view that only
humans have souls right and of course
the pan psychist view that everything
has a soul even say a proton that's also
pretty bizarre right so then there are
two other options right one is that
there's a sharp line somewhere right so
okay dogs have souls cats have
souls but not
frogs where do you draw that line right
across the Continuum of animals it seems
like there's a Continuum of
psychological capacities a Continuum of
physiology it'd be weird if you said
okay to toads of this genus have souls
toads of this other genus do not right
so a sharp sharp line
is pretty
implausible at least bizarre right and
and then that gives you maybe the fourth
option which is having a soul is not an
on or off thing you could have a kind of
Soul or a half Soul right so maybe like
frogs have like you know an eighth of a
soul I mean what would that even mean we
normally think of souls as things that
you either have or don't have it seems
like a a discret category rather than a
graded category right so but you got to
take one of those horns right but
they're all bizarre right so that's that
illustrates
why I think you know on the face of it
it seems like oh having a soul is not a
bizarre view right but as soon as you
face that choice of saying okay what
animals have souls you you're just
you're forced into uh committing to some
strikingly bizarre position and as a
matter of fact this was a Hot Topic in
ancient philosophy which animals have
souls right exactly right and in ancient
well I mean and the modern conception of
the soul is the locus of Consciousness
is uh a little different from an ancient
philosoph
there was the vegetative Soul as well so
there's a sense in which even plants had
Souls but they didn't think of souls
maybe as a locus of Consciousness so
actually the the concept of a soul that
we find in our current philosophical and
religious tradition has a has a certain
history it isn't not a straightforward
translation from say ancient Greek so
it's complicated but yes it's been an
issue uh throughout philosophical
history but here at the mindscape
podcasts we are hardcore materialists
about Consciousness so tell us why that
leads us to
weirdness
um
well one of the issues here to think
about is again what kind of entities
have
experiences guess there are a few
different ways to angle in on this
but one of them uh and this is uh this
is the theme of chapter
is to point out
that according to a broad class of
materialist theories it's very plausible
that the United States has a stream of
conscious experience right the United
States conceived of as a concrete entity
with people as its parts kind of like
you are a concrete entity with cells as
your parts right so think about that
concrete thing mhm with hundreds of
billions of people right hundreds of
millions sorry hundreds of
millions sorry I misspoke there don't
want you misquoted
yeah uh
so that entity processes a lot of
information that entity represents
itself that entity responds to its
environment kind of intell ently or semi
intelligently right you scan space for
asteroids that might threaten Earth and
we're prepared to try to deal with them
if that happens the United States
monitors its borders it engages in
Import and Export it sends this Army out
to do certain things it scolds people in
un Security Council
meetings uh it digests
bananas mounts of bananas right it
exudes smoggy
exhalations so
if you if you take kind of standard
materialist theories of Consciousness
kind of out of the box and you don't
kind of around with them post Hawk to
try to exclude the the case then I think
it turns out
that probably the United States is going
to count as Consciousness as
conscious so there there are a couple
ways to react to the this you could say
okay well so much the worse for
materialism M or you could say okay well
look you know we need to mess around
with these theories to exclude this
bizarre
possibility um and I think that is maybe
a reasonable
response one question here is how we
know the United States is not conscious
whether you should take that as a fixed
point in our theorizing about
Consciousness or
not you know and the third possibility
is to say okay well maybe there is group
Consciousness I
mean we don't have a conscious ometer
that we could put up against the head of
the United States doesn't even really
have a head right to determine whether
it's
conscious so that would be one area
where I
think if you accept the United States as
conscious then you end up that's I I
take that as a pretty bizarre kind of
view if you don't then you adopt other
theoretical commitments and then we
could get into the details of those but
I think those other theoretical
commitments often then involve kind of
further choices among various bizarre
possibilities right kind of like with
the immaterial soul case
right as soon as you start making those
commitments once you develop them you
see oh boy this is going to have this
this consequence this is pretty
unintuitive well
how certain should we be in that
conclusion is there a theorem that says
that any version of
materialist theories of Consciousness
are going to have this property or is it
just well as far as we know according to
our best current art that seems to be
the case in other words could the
appearance of bizar go away with better
understanding um yes it could and there
are two separate reasons right one is
kind of as you suggested right unlike
the what I call the dualist
quadrama I don't think we we have a kind
of rigorous argument that all of the
choices have to be bizarre it's that the
choices that I've seen articulated all
have bizarre consequences yeah okay but
there might be some unarticulated choice
that I haven't run across yet that turns
out to be common sensical right so I
think that's possible but empirically
unlikely given the current state of
things and the history of philosophical
discussion on this so it's an empirical
conjecture the other way in which
bizares could end up Vanishing is our
intuitions and our sense of Common Sense
could change right so the idea that the
Earth moved around the Sun was bizarre
when cernus suggested it but we no
longer seem to find that a sharp
violation of Common Sense Common Sense
has changed over time right so it could
be that someday we'll find it very
common sensical for example that the
United States is
conscious oh yeah of course or maybe pan
psychism oh the whole universe is
conscious right the ordinary person in
the street of course they think that
right Common Sense can change it's not a
fixed it's not a fixed
point and we should so it's a little bit
different than the previous examples of
the skeptical scenarios right here
unless I'm misinterpreting you're not
arguing that we should hold out 1%
Credence for some bizarre possibilities
you're you're just saying look all the
possibilities seem to Bear bizarre we
should I guess learn to accept that or
fold that in not use it as a drag as a
as a knockout argument against something
we can't say well I can't accept that
it's bizarre cuz all the other options
are
too exactly so this is why people like
pists and idealists like my stuff on
this right because part of the
reason the main reason I think people
reject pan psychism for example the idea
that everything in the universe or maybe
the universe is a whole is conscious is
that it just seems so contrary to common
sense but if I'm right well something
contrary to Common Sense is probably
true so maybe that's it right so right I
mean I do think we have to rely on
common sense to some extent I don't
think we can just toss it out the window
when we talk about issues like this um
we don't have in my view really any
great tools for answering these
questions and so we have to rely on
highly imperfect ones like common sense
um but the fact that that something
violates common sense is not
automatically defeat it it does seem
very similar to things that even I have
said about quantum mechanics uh I I
presume that we're going to put the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics into the bucket of things that
you would say are pretty
bizarre
yes I remember a a quote from I think it
was David Murman who is a very famous
very great physicist who uh is a
epistemic person when it comes to
quantum mechanics so he thinks the wave
function is just a tool for
understanding our knowledge and
prediction not reflecting anything real
and you know he does little surveys of
the field Etc and at some point comes to
um many worlds and he says yes you can
follow the shinger equation and its
consequences and you end up with a
theory and the price you pay is
seriousness so basically he's just
saying like surely you can't take that
seriously right and that's it that's the
entire argument and that feels like not
a good enough argument to me because
like you said in the in the context of
Consciousness for me every version of
quantum mechanics is going to lead us
somewhere
strange right in fact I
think the I like the interpretations of
quantum mechanics as an illustration of
what I call the universal duety and the
universal Bizness claim because I think
maybe especially your listeners will
find that plausible right every viable
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
bizarre there's no like Common Sense way
of thinking about quantum mechanics
right and you know with apologies to the
many
worlds Advocates right they're all
dubious right there's at least grounds
for doubting all of them I don't mean by
when I say dubious I don't mean that we
have to assign a very low Credence to
them but it's reasonable to be doubtful
among them to not feel like ah we're EP
Ally compelled to accept many worlds
over all the other
interpretations so it's a good
interpretation a Quantic mechanics is a
good example of a a domain in which I
think the universal dubiety and
Universal bizares claim is true and then
I want to say the same thing about say
the theories of Consciousness right uh
and theories of the fundamental
structure of the cosmos uh and both of
those I think are I mean the
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
the nature of Consciousness are both
part of fundamental structure of the
cosmos so you kind of almost get that
for free once you get those two you know
I I generally when pressed put my
Credence in many worlds at between 90%
And 95% you depending on the the time of
day I'll give one of those two numbers
and I did that in conversation with
Philip Goff famous pan psychist in
previous mindscape cast and he was just
flabbergasted he's like you you give a
95% Creed to the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics I'm
like dude you're a pan psychist you
think electrons have feelings don't give
me a hard time for giving large Credence
to following the Sher equation I'm
[Laughter]
sorry right totally fair totally fair I
mean I wouldn't give many worlds quite
that high an interpretation I think we
should be uh more more epistemically
cautious about our favorite
interpretation of quantum mechanics but
but yeah there's room for reasonable
disagreement I I think if you're in the
ballpark of 90 to
95% you're getting on the cusp of
denying Universal uh
duety but you know
how what exactly counts as being dubious
is kind of a fuzzy you do suggest in the
book that when you're in this position
where every option is bizarre we should
give fairly large credences to the
competing possibilities because we kind
of don't have a right to be too
confident when about prefer ing one
bizarre alternative to other bizarre
Alternatives we shouldn't be too
definitive yes um I think that's
generally true about the kinds of
questions that we're asking because I
think we have basically three broad
types of epistemic grounds we're
choosing among these theories right one
is common sense which is how we've
already talked about is going to be
imperfect and things are going to
violate it these theories are going to
violate it one respect or
another another is scientific evidence
you know kind of just direct scientific
evidence you know like measure it right
and on something like whether electrons
have souls or what interpretation of
quantum mechanics is
correct we don't we can't now at least
run an experiment that says Ah Yeah this
experiment proves obviously on the face
of it the many worlds interpretation
right and then the third tool we have is
something like theoretical Elegance
and again that's kind of going to be
indecisive because you know there's
something elegant about pan psychism and
there's something elegant about
materialism and there's something
elegant about many worlds and there's
something elegant about other approaches
too so these are not going to be they're
going to be tradeoffs among these very
imperfect ways of trying to settle these
questions rather than
um strong solid
grounds well I wanted to ask you this
specifically in the context of quantum
mechanics because I I've put it the
following way sometimes I wanted to see
how it fits in with your views if you
take something like hidden variables
versions of quantum mechanics so those
listeners who don't know what I'm
talking about we did an episode with Tim
modlin recently where he will explain
and in those theories you have particles
and they have locations and that's what
you observe when you do a measurement
and then you also have a wave function
and it's the phenomenology is much Clos
cler to the world than it is in
something like many worlds where you
have this abstract wave function and
there's many copies of reality Etc I I
think that there's much less Elegance
Simplicity austerity to the hidden
variables version as a theory I I think
this is indisputable I think that
whether you agree that it's the best
theory or not you should you should also
agree it's a clunkier theory than many
worlds many worlds is very simple and
and austere but I should also uh accept
that many worlds is much further away
from our everyday life and our
experience than the hidden variables
theory is so the question is how do we
weigh these different considerations
like how it's it's good to have a simple
Theory it's also good to have one that
tells you pretty directly and and
immediately what it predicts and how to
understand it I mean how do we be good
philosophers and scientists when we're
faced with that kind of choice
right exactly and I'd say just leave
that hanging as a question so I am
inclined to agree one of the things I
mean you're much more expert on this
than I am but one of the things that I
like about many worlds is it is have a
certain kind of Simplicity to it and
these other theories all seem to involve
a certain amount of fussing
around um but uh right how do you weigh
that against other aspects uh that
reasonably draw people to resist many
worlds and prefer these other
approaches and I don't think that there
is a really good General answer to that
kind of question and that's one of the
reasons to have kind of non-extreme
credences in these various theoretical
possibilities good yeah so and if you do
have non-extreme credences then you can
hope for Progress you can hope to get
better uh I guess maybe you know to wind
up the conversation I like giving
actionable um advice to you know the
people out there we've talked a little
about how to deal with these crazy
things maybe to go back to that idea
that I'd never heard of before nickelos
and discounting maybe that's the same
idea
as when the when the your credences get
small enough I'm allowed to stop
thinking about it is that right you know
that is this basically the idea yeah
that's basically the idea I I think that
idea is important and but I mean maybe
part of your
message in the book is don't be quite so
quick to dismiss the tiny or more
bizarre possibilities I don't know is
that is that
right yes that is one of the
messages absolutely I think that we have
a people will tend to have a gut
reaction
against views that that strike them as
bizarre whether it's many worlds or pan
psychism or the idea that you know only
humans have souls or whatever it is um
and I think there's reason to take that
kind of reaction
seriously but there's also reason to
not just rely on that and to allow that
some of these theories that you might
think are so bizarre as to be
absurd maybe they're only bizarre and
not actually absurd
well I guess I I'm I'm caught maybe in a
little bit of hypocrisy here because
that's exactly what I want to say to
David Merman and his friends like he
will just dismiss many worlds even
though he's a brilliant physicist he'll
just say that that's too bizarre I'm
just not going to accept that and I want
to say no you have to take it seriously
but then there are other people pan
pists maybe are an example who will say
who I will say no that's too
bizarre I don't need it and I I not
quite sure what the principal stance is
here right yeah maybe you should give a
little bit of your Creedence space to
pan psychism but there is I guess just a
little you know but there I maybe maybe
here is the issue there's sort of in
principal Credence space and then
there's what I will spend my time
worrying about Credence space right like
when the credences become so small I'm
not going to lose sleep over it even if
maybe someday evidence will come in that
will change my
mind right yeah that's fair that's fair
yeah especially as a as an academic
choice right so there's there's also
this question of what do you spend your
academic time thinking about what do you
invest your energy in and even if you
were to say give a non-trivial say 5%
Credence to pan psychism that's not
tiny but that might not be an worth
enough of your academic time uh to build
theories on
I have spent more time than my Credence
would warrant thinking about pan
psychism so I should take this this
advice very well so you've given it more
than as 5% due I think so I think so
anyway Eric schwitz Gable this was uh if
it was all a dream it was a very uh fun
dream to have so I appreciate thanks
very much for being on the mindscape
podcast yeah thanks for having me it's
been
[Music]
fun
yeah